I thank you so I'd like to talk about
some tests that we can run on small
quantum devices these are going to
include tests of quantum physics some of
these are going to have applications
especially to cryptography and some of
them hopefully will determine how we can
help how we can build future quantum
voices but they should all be applicable
to two near-term quanto devices so very
small devices not the start quantum
computer
so let me just get started the first
test is is of dimensionality so when we
have only half and qubits this gives us
a 2 to the n dimensional hilbert space
and perhaps this might seem a bit of
extravagant maybe even unbelievably so
one might hypothesize that nature is
actually a bit more parsimonious in that
physically relevant States perhaps stay
within a corner of this Hilbert space
that perhaps only has polynomial many
parameters for example state satisfying
areolas I'm going to try to test a even
stronger hypothesis which is that our n
cubed system the qubits are not in
tensor product but instead they're
packed closely together and more closely
together and in fact that these n qubits
perhaps could live inside just a system
of just polynomial in many dimensions do
you mean
yes we can efficiently prepare our
probably no we leave any parameters
right it's just that it's not a subspace
yeah I I do mean a space of 2 to the N
dimensions so let me start with an
example a classical example so we can
understand the setup here here's a
memory card you can buy an Amazon 64
gigabyte card before buying it you might
want to look at the reviews a bit
because here's a typical one-star review
he bought the card it works fine up to
about 10 gigabytes and then it starts
corrupting files and I don't know
exactly what's going on with this
particular card one hypothesis is that
it's something like this you plug it
into your computer it reports that it
has 64 gigabytes of memory but in fact
there's only maybe 8 or 10 gigabytes
inside the card and it's sort of over
over using the same memory many times so
so there are applications you can
download to test for this kind of thing
I don't know if you trust the
application anymore then you trust the
the card but basically one might guess
the kind of tests of these saw that the
software could run is it stores 64
gigabytes of random data into the card
and it reads it back off and sees
whether the data matched what it would
is storage or not and in fact you don't
have to read back all of the data it's
enough to measure say one of one of the
bits at random to see whether it was
correctly correctly story
so we could of course imagine the same
thing happening quantumly that are 64
million cubed system is being packed
into just a much smaller one but in fact
quantum systems can concede in more
interesting ways than the classical
systems can in particular you can have
two qubits that are not entirely on top
of each other but they just slightly
overlap so mathematically what it means
for qubits to overlap is that an
operation well what is what does it mean
for Q's to be in tensor product it means
in an operation on one of them can't
affect the other so conversely qubits
that overlap slightly means that an
operation on one of them can just
slightly perhaps by epsilon effect the
effect of the other qubit so this is a
definition of pairwise overlap and
allowing pairwise overlapped allowing
pairwise overlap Epsilon our first
theorem says that you can in fact you
can packed
you can pack n qubits into just
polynomially many dimensions and more
quantitatively if the overlap is epsilon
then you can fit in into n to the one
over epsilon squared dimensions this is
sort of a random packing argument so
this shows here in plotting the overlap
versus the needed dimension this shows
that is if the overlap is large enough
roughly more than one over squared of n
then the number of dimensions can be
much smaller than an exponential
conversely we show that if the overlap
is smaller than one over n then the
overlap then the dimension really does
need to be exponential you can't have
super small pairwise overlap in less
than two
this middle region we're not quite sure
so so so that that shows that in theory
many qubits can be packed into into just
a few dimensions we also give a test for
for seeing whether this happens in in
your real system for for verifying that
your particular system does have
exponentially many dimensions and the
test is actually the same as the
classical test I just showed you almost
so instead of storing n random bits we
store and random qubits meaning either
ket 0 ket 1 cap plus or cap - then you
retrieve or we measure a random one of
those and see that it's what it should
have been so our theorem says that if
you pass this test with high probability
then the dimension has to be
exponentially large so this factor of N
squared is a little bit problematic for
for small scale systems but otherwise
it's it's a reasonable test so but
there's there's there's some room for
improvement there
and it's a pretty simple attest to
implement as well right so the second
test I'd like to explain is is one for
entanglement so how do you know that you
have an you have an entangled state for
example a cat state 0 0 + 1 1 the
simplest answer is to apply state
tomography so you can measure each qubit
in the Z basis or measure each qubit in
the X basis and if you measure them both
in the Z basis you should get even
parity if you measure them both in the X
basis you should get even parity as well
of course this this can be used for a
quantum key distribution scheme that the
same idea so you have two parties Alice
and Bob and they measure each of them at
random in either the Z basis or the X
basis and if they get the same answer
all the time so you throw away some of
the trials and to make sure that they're
getting the same answer and then then on
the trials that you haven't thrown away
if they've measured in the same basis
that gives you a random key 'but that's
provably secure from the environment
because this this state 0 0+1 1 is
monogamous between the between the two
parties
unfortunately the state tomography is
not the best way for securely showing
that you have entanglement for example
if your photons instead of being
two-dimensional systems if there's
actually if they're actually four
dimensional systems then they can
satisfy these same correlations without
using any entanglement so so here's
here's one way that could happen so in
fact not only are they four dimensional
systems but they're four dimensional
classical systems so they just store two
bits in each in each of these photons or
in each of these systems
telling you what the response should be
if you're measured in the Z basis and
telling you what the response should be
if you're measured in the X basis and
it's the same for Allison for Bob so
they always pass the test but there's no
entanglement and this of course is
rather bad for security because it means
that an adversary Eve could could know
what the key is I just have a copy of
the classical information okay so if we
come on if we want to prove this we can
extend the game so instead of just
making sure that they give you the same
answer when you ask them the same
question you can you can ask for
correlations when you ask some different
questions when you ask Alice to measure
in the Z basis x2 and Bob to measure in
the X basis or vice-versa
and so we want their answers in this
case to be the same in this case to be
different this is called the the CH SH
game and if the devices are not
entangled a circle if their classical
then they can only win in three out of
the four of these possibilities so
seventy-five percent chance of winning
if they're quantum entangled they can
win it's probably up to about eighty
five percent so that gives you a ten
percent gap there that lets you really
show that you have an entangled system
the idea is you're going to run this run
this game maybe a million times and if
you win seventy six percent or maybe
eighty percent at least eighty percent
of them then that's fairly strong
statistical evidence that these that the
devices are not merely classical
in fact this has been tested fairly
recently this was in 20 2015 where they
gave the first what's called loophole
free Bell inequality and so loophole
free in this case means that they
managed to get their measurement there
and detection air below this 10% gap and
also that they managed I guess to do it
with systems that are spaceless
spatially separated far enough so at the
speed of light going from one to the
other
the measurements are finished before any
possible coordinate coordination could
could have happened or even more
recently this has been people have tried
to deal with the question of are the
questions into the system really random
or not and these are just sort of fun
experiments on and in the first
experiment they point telescopes in
opposite directions in order to collect
photons that are certainly independent
of each other
hopefully in the second experiment they
have people press buttons on their it
had a hundred thousand people pressing
buttons on their computers in order to
generate randomness and test soviet so
in fact there's stronger tests out there
so so this is the optimal content
strategy there's a theorem that says not
only is it the case that better than 75
percent implies entanglement but if
you're close to 85 percent so if you're
85 percent minus epsilon then you have
to be behaving according to this
particular quantum strategy so you have
to have a state that's at square root of
epsilon close to that cat state and the
and the measurements have to be scored
of epsilon close as well we can extend
this test even further by playing many
chssh games in order to test not only
that I have one bit of one qubit worth
of entanglement which is not so
impressive but to test that I have many
qubits worth of entanglement which is
which is pretty cool
so our first test what was the following
theorem that you just play many games
sequentially unable to show that you
have polynomial e many qubits worth of
entanglement since then there's been
more and more efficient tests
this also does have applications one of
the application is is to what's called
device independent quantum key
distribution so in here you want to
establish a secure channel between two
parties and device independent lets us
really do this securely with only these
four assumptions so in particular we do
not have to trust that the devices are
behaving according to some specification
and in fact the communication can be
done even if your crypto devices have
been manufactured by your adversary I
made in China in this case because if
the device is try to cheat either you'll
do you'll detect it for for sure
otherwise they want people to pass your
test
okay and and it also has applications
even beyond this so so in terms of
testing quantum devices or testing
quantum computers some problems you can
check the answer for example factoring
you can even multiply the factors
together again but for a quantum
simulation it's not so easy to check the
answer we come up with what's called a
protocol for a secure delegated quantum
computation which is built on this sub
protocol of multiple CH sh games played
sequentially and then has a few other
sub protocols as well but our main
theorem says that if you have two
separated quantum of devices again call
it an Alice and Bob then you can in fact
certify the dynamics and this is
interesting in fact I think because
naively you might you might think that
quanto devices are much more powerful
than classical devices and so they can
cheat and many more may be more
complicated many more interesting ways
but but in fact did this this kind of
theorem shows that even though quantum
systems are more powerfully you think
you can give them more interesting tests
and this restricts them more more
strictly than than classical devices
could could be restricted so so in fact
untrusted quantum systems can be
controlled stronger than untrusted
classical systems I think on Friday
there's going to be a lot of the talk
said that extend this and do it have
some better theorems or for delegated
computation
that's maybe not a near-term point of a
third test is is of nonlocality
so the reason people are interested at
first in this CH SH game was not just
for to test for entangle on but was
really to test basic foundational
quantum physics so there's this question
does does God play dice is is underneath
quantum physics underneath it is her a
classical model that's actually
deterministic so you might imagine that
inside this photon when you send a
photon through polarizing filter inside
the photon there's just a long list
what's called a local a local hidden
variable model that says if I'm measured
in this particular direction this this
is the measurement outcome and so on and
so the test was originally developed to
rule out these local hidden variables or
what are called local realist models so
and this is the einstein-podolsky-rosen
local local realism model so local means
that each party's result depends only on
that party's measurement settings so
there's no faster-than-light
communication possible realist means
deterministic so so we've shown that
there is a separation one one might ask
to extend this what if there's an
underlying classical model of physics
that's local but not realist so it's a
it's a local and randomized in fact such
models of physics do exist
there's one called the popescu Warlick
non-local box or more generally a non
simulating classical distribution this
is a box that wins the chssh game with
probability 1 so in fact this chssh game
does not rule out a classical
explanation it does allow us to have a
non signaling classical explanation
so we come up with a test to rule out
non signaling correlations in particular
we show that there exists a three party
game in fact where the quantumly the
three parties only need qubits only need
a cat state so it's a not too
experimental challenging to create where
the best quantum strategy wins with
probability about 92 or 93 percent
whereas I don't know the best classical
strategy I guess it's probably 75% again
yes but but the best two-party non
signaling strategy is only eighty seven
point five percent so there's about a
five percent gap there but between the
quantum and the non signaling strategy
so this hopefully gives us a test that
we can use to rule out this this this
classical model this is this potential
Alaska model
and the game is very simple it's
actually just an extension of the CHS
the difficult here is is that so the
model really is is that each of these
parties shares many either purpose glue
or lick boxes or in fact arbitrary to
party non signaling correlations and
they can use them in an arbitrary way
feeding the outputs of one into the
inputs of the next in a completely
adaptive manner we're able to rule out
this kind of strategy
the fourth test is of thought tolerance
so so what's what's the problem here if
we want to run out a large-scale quantum
quantum algorithm for example Shor's
algorithm to factor a 1024 bit number
we need roughly 10 to the 11 gates in
that case which means you need an error
rate of about 10 to the minus 11 11 per
gate which is infeasible low because in
typical physical systems noise rates are
generally around maybe a percent maybe
in the future they'll improve to perhaps
10 to the minus 4 air per gate
fortunately we can deal with this gap
using software so so you using what's
called photons so instead of applying
the circuit for factoring your number
you compile that circuit into a larger
fault tolerant circuit using a quantum
error correcting code in in a careful
way and in that way you can reduce the
effective noise or a per effective gate
from 10 minus 2 or 10 minus 4 all the
way down to 10 - 11 quite quite
efficiently
so this is a rather amazing theory we
don't know what whether it's actually
going to work it hasn't been tested
experimentally and so so what are some
of the problems we have these theorems
these these abstract theorems that say
it should work but they're their own
they're only for ideal in all these
models which might not be the noise that
actually rises in in the physical
systems so in particular some problems
could be that the noise in your system
has correlated errors instead of
independent errors and if the
correlations are strong enough this
could break our theorems and so it might
be that actually fault tolerance is not
possible and we can't build a
large-scale quantum computer another
possible problem is is is the noise
could be coherent in service for castex
so the difference is stochastic noise
probabilities just add if you've any
errors at rate P the probability of an
errors is roughly n times P coherent
noise the amplitudes adds so so if
you've n phases of angle theta the total
phases n times theta which means that
the probability of an error goes like N
squared theta squared so it's growing
quadratically which means the threshold
could be quadratically lower than we
think and so if we think that we can
tolerate 1% noise maybe in fact we
normally tolerate 0.01% noise
challenging for experiments to achieve
that's the first question will [ __ ]
horns work oh and I don't know that we
really know a second question is how
will photons work and at a very high
level you could say there's two main
approaches to to fault tolerance there
there's concatenated codes which are
good for low low noise rates and there's
surface codes which are good if you have
limited connections and which approach
is better is not entirely clear and in
fact it's much more complicated than
this so so there's many options for
building a photonic computer there's
many codes to choose for each quantum
error correcting code there's many ways
of using that particular code of doing
error correction of preparing the states
of applying the gates and so on of
course it's not anything that even that
simple because it's not just choosing
one code you can combine different codes
in clever ways if I concatenation or
even at the same time so there's lots of
you you can't say that one approach is
better than another approach because
there's lots of different regimes as
well so for example you could have local
gates geometrically local gates or you
can have for example in superconducting
systems or we could have range gates
which which are more possible in ion
traps we might have fast versus slow
measurements or good versus bad memory
higher low rest errors or or high versus
low errors so the scheme that you use
depends on how even if you're below the
threshold for toggle and noise if you're
well below the threshold then you then
you're going to want to use completely
different codes and if you're if you're
quite close to the threshold so all its
sensitive to all these all these
possibilities and unfortunately even
though ultimately we're going to have to
build engineer these massive quantum
devices it's quite hard to know where
we're we're going to be and what we need
to do because simulations are are quite
difficult obviously because they're
there they're large quantum systems and
and the analytical balance that we have
are generally too conservative
so the goal I'd like to propose is is to
test photons and in particular to test
photons on very small quantum devices
were highly qubit limited terminal
devices I think this is important to
test the theory to show that the theory
actually works with real annoys models
not just not just in theory to see how
well the the theory works to see how
well the photon schemes work and then
hopefully to to adapt the photon schemes
and possibly to adapt the devices in the
future to how well you find the schemes
are working this hasn't been done yet I
just I don't know a lot last week or a
couple weeks ago Flaminio Tao showed
showed demonstrated photons with an
arrow detecting code nobody's done it
within the air with error correction yet
I don't think and the basic reason is is
that it's it's difficult and you need
lots of qubits so previously for example
if you wanted to store one logical qubit
fought on LI you could you could use for
example a7 cubed steam code and then
you're gonna have to use more qubits for
error correction so these are called in
silico bits so 12 total qubits or you
could use for example include this one
qubit into the nine cubed bacon short
code and then plus one for error
correction so overall overall still you
need ten qubits which is not a tiny
number of qubits in order to test air
we're able to improve this so we show
that you can encode one logical qubit
into five the five cubic code and then
just have two cubits for error
correction so seven cubits total it's
just a little bit smaller but it
hopefully makes it just a little bit
more practical or or 1 into 7 plus 2 or
say 7 logical qubits into 15 plus 2 and
here not only can you can you encode the
7 logical qubits into 15 plus 2 but you
can also do computation photonic
computation on the encoded qubits these
numbers of qubits like 15 cubits and so
I don't have a chronic computer with 50
humans and actually like like the the
qubits are the computers are for example
IBM's device it has it has a problem
for one thing the noise rates are rather
high but maybe maybe that's okay maybe
that's okay another problem is is that
you can't reset and reuse the same
qubits right now so so you you can
measure a qubit and that's measured for
good you can't one say once they fix
that then then I think you can you can
start testing well we have adapted some
of these things with better connectivity
but that's also another issue
so the basic idea the basic problem with
Florence is that error spread so for
example here this an error at this
location could spread to two multiple
qubits previously people have tried to
avoid this are our differences that we
don't try to avoid air we don't try to
keep errors from spreading we just try
to catch them this I guess is part of a
bigger moral in fault-tolerant quantum
computing which is if you can detect
errors it's much better than if you
can't that's just what we're doing here
and although in this case it actually
reduces the overhead into increasing and
so we use this idea in in a lot of
different ways
[Applause]
that happens I think there are and and I
think there are better examples and lots
of things and in particular probably the
the nearest term quantum algorithms are
going to be more like quantum chemistry
algorithms that we saw yesterday which
would require many many fewer qubits
that was just but but they still
probably will need will need for
tolerance but a it certainly at a
smaller scale so is this BR box to
window CHS gain higher from ability does
this fall under any of the normal
loopholes or is this outside of the
general loopholes that you think up in
developing phones yes so you know it's
it's outside that it's not considered
you have a sense of whatever it you
needed for these fun photo post yeah so
we have simulations and I think let's
see so all right so we've done limited
simulations so the simulations we've
done have been with non-local gates and
with so we've done it with and without
rest airs so we're extracting the
syndromes one at a time so so rest areas
are painful without rest areas they're
competitive with almost kind of numbers
with rest areas it's a little bit below
that but I don't think it's
okay I don't know it didn't like the
appendix of our paper but I don't
remember yeah resetting is a major issue
do you have any way to quantify that how
many operations do you need of resetting
no I know I think that's an interesting
question I think there's interesting
questions here which is for example
we've just been trying to minimize the
number of qubits that you use with
faster you said but you could also say
what about the question of minimizing a
number of qubits that you use with slow
reset so you can't reuse this we've
looked at this for some problems but not
for all of them it's just interesting
other variants as well
well I mean for example here you need
two cubits every time you extract a
syndrome and so that when you extract
the next syndrome you're going to have
to have reset the same two cubits or
have four cubits to per one syndrome or
one bit of syndrome
that's sorry but just going back you
know when you were just talking about
error correction including with this
yeah I mean if for example in the in the
nine cubed scheme you're gonna have to
do it
well those resets or ish in in the seven
cubed scheme you're gonna have I don't
know six six
[Applause]